wir sprechen jetzt mit dem virologen
professor bernhard fleckenstein herr
professor die hersteller von astrazeneca
erklären dass es zwei gründe gibt warum
sie nicht geplant liefern können zum
einen ist das ein großbrand in indien
der die produktion gestoppt hat und zum
anderen soll der impfstoff an die
mutationen angepasst werden was heißt
das jetzt genau was ist das genaue
problem ja das problem besteht darin
dass den impfstoff der ein vector
impfstoff ist anzupassen an die neuen
virus varianten wahrscheinlich mehr zeit
kosten würde als das für die erna
impfstoffe gilt und ich sehe da
natürlich ein großes problem
einerseits ist vorgesehen oder erwartet
man dass in der nächsten woche eine
lizenz auch in europa kommen wird
auf der anderen seite jetzt die sorge
dass die neuen virus varianten durch den
impfstoff vielleicht nicht ganz
abgedeckt sind
da haben wir ein objektives problem
das ist kein politisches problem das ist
ein biologisches gruppe und herr
professor wir haben ja unglaublich viele
impfdosen von genau diesem hersteller
gekauft angenommen der impfstoff wirkt
nicht gegen die mutationen was passiert
dann wie lange würde sich das ganze
verzögern wie lange würde das dauern
darüber kann ich nur spekulieren aber
sicher länger als die vermuteten sechs
wochen bei einem rna im stoff also ich
glaube nach wie vor die speerspitze des
kampfes gegen das virus sind im
augenblick die rna impfstoffe von
biontech von moderner und hoffentlich
bald von kurt beck
und wie schnell astrazeneca mit
möglichen geologischen problemen zurecht
kommt das kann ich nicht beurteilen aber
ich würde und befürchten dass das
rückschläge bedeutet ich habe auch noch
eine frage und zwar wir hören auch das
biontech der impfstoff der ja gepriesen
worden ist mit einer extrem hohen
wirksamkeit von von 95 prozent über alle
altersgruppen stimmt ist denn das dass
das bei den wirklich alten nicht ganz so
hoch ist in denen der wirksamkeit dass
ich dass sie sich jetzt zeigt das mag
sein aber insgesamt gehen wir aus von
einer wirksamkeit von 95 prozent
und wenn bei älteren personen dann die
wirksamkeit etwas niedriger sein sollte
wäre das immer noch ein günstiger
bereich bei den vektor impfstoffen von
astra zenica gehen wir aus von einer
wirksamkeit von schätzungsweise 70
prozent und dort ist die wirksamkeit bei
älteren menschen noch nicht hinreichend
untersucht
also meine persönliche meinung ist dass
die rna impfstoffe die speerspitze sind
das was uns die chance gibt und wir
können nur hoffen dass astrazeneca
langsam mit seien seine versprechungen
auch einhalten kann
vorgesehen waren 80 millionen impfdosen
jetzt ist die rede vom 31 millionen im
stoßen
das ist ein schlimmer rückschlag also
wir können nur das beste hoffen wir
können aber das nicht davon ausgehen
dass politiker dass der staat sehr viel
dazu beitragen kann ich persönlich setze
mehr auf deren stoffe die den rna
impfstoffen sind wirklich die modernsten
konzepte des immun genetik realisiert er
ist ganz spezifisch enthält er nur die
genetische substanz und zwar nur rna für
das eigentliche spike protein und sonst
nichts
und er ist sehr rasch modifizierbar
und hat eine relativ einfache
herstellungsart also meine persönliche
hoffnung ist ganz und gar den rna
impfstoffen von beyond eck und pfizer
hoffentlich in größerem umfang wald von
moderner und braucht nicht auch weil
schon photowerk es gab beim astra
weniger impfstoff ja schon in der phase
3 studie ungewöhnlichkeit und zu mal
vorsichtig auszudrücken es fehlten
einfach die alten in unternehmen
probanden dann jetzt soll der impfstoff
zugelassen werden rechnen sie denn damit
dass der impfstoff auch für ältere
zugelassen wird oder wurde eine 65
zulassung geben also nur für leute unter
65 verschickt und ergreifend in der
phase 3 studie diese probanden fehlten
die alten also da würde ich mir wenig
davon zu sprechen
denn nach den vorgaben der stiko ist es
ja so dass ohnehin die älteren die alten
als aller erstes immunisiert werden
sollten hätten wir einen impfstoff an
der hand der dafür gar nicht lizenziert
ist dann macht das alles keinen sinn
ich würde vermuten dass die lizenzierung
ausgesprochen wird auch für die älteren
menschen aber wir wissen nicht wie hoch
die wirksamkeit dann sein muss und wir
müssen uns noch etwas überlegen wenn die
neuen varianten diese nelly varianten
aus großbritannien südafrika aus nigeria
aus brasilien
tatsächlich höhere kontaktlosen höher
ansteckend sind und davon das ist ja das
große problem das ist die furcht die wir
alle haben dann würde auch eine
herdenimmunität nicht erreicht wenn nur
70 prozent infiziert sind dann bräuchten
wir eine höhere herdenimmunität
und wie sollen wir die erreichen mit
einem impfstoff der möglicherweise nur
niedriger als 70 prozent wirksam ist
ich persönlich das ist ja genau war ein
problem wir haben ja als der britische
entschuldung das ist hinter wochen habe
wir haben ja den tischen im stall wir
haben die britischen mutationen bei 117
die als hochgefährlich
daraufhin haben wir ja den gesamten
flugverkehr den ganzen verkehr zu
großbritannien unterbrochen
jetzt gibt es noch die brasilianische wm
in südafrika ähnlich gemacht jetzt gibt
es diese hoch gefährliche mutation auch
aus brasilien und heute sind zum
beispiel aus in frankfurt am main noch
zwei flüge aus sao paulo angekommen wie
kann das denn sein dass da immer noch
flüge kommen was sagen sie als
wissenschaftler dazu dass wir jetzt noch
flügel aus solchen risiko extrem
risikogebieten haben wie brasilien
das ist keine wissenschaftliche sondern
eine politische frage warum solche
flugzeuge noch landen dürfen
der eigentliche ausbruch ist ja auch in
amazonien und nicht in sao paulo
aber natürlich macht es sinn
reiseaktivitäten zu unterbrechen wenn
wir davon ausgehen müssen dass der
anteil dieser nelly varianten sehr hoch
ist in brasilien und auch hoch ist in
großbritannien usw
und dann machen reise unterbrechungen
sind auch dann wenn wir relativ wenige
oder wenn wir weniger relativ wenige
fälle von solchen infektionen im jetzt
in deutschland haben macht es einen
unterschied ob wir zusätzlich die viren
importieren oder ob wir hoffen können
dass es noch eine weile dauern bis die
viren sich ausbreiten herr professor
vielen dank für ihre zeit und einen
schönen abend an sie dankeschön
gleichfalls mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei der schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren